good morning it's the morning after
Thanksgiving and I'm still feeling sick
with food but I will move forward into
s80 videos so we are on where are we we
are on the third test and this is it
called the official s80 study guide on
page 5 18 section 2 so it's the first
math section in this third test and
let's get started with the problem so
the first problem is 3x plus 9 is equal
to 5x plus 1 and they want to know X so
this is just a straightforward algebra
problem all you can do is so it's a
sweet i'll end up with negative numbers
let's subtract 1 from both sides so you
get 3x plus 8 is equal to 5x subtract 3x
from both sides you get 8 is equal to
two x divide both sides by 2 you get 4
is equal to x or x is equal to 4 choice
D problem number two that was just a
straightforward problem problem number
two they give us a little sequence here
so it's 715 3163 and it just keeps going
and says the first term of the sequence
107 and each term after the first is
determined by multiplying the preceding
term by M and then adding n so we
multiplied by M and then added n okay
what is the value of ammo well you can
just look at what they're doing right
what do they have to what do you have to
multiply 7 by and add to get to 15 well
7 times 2 plus 1 is equal to 15 right 7
times 2 plus 1 is equal to 15 and if you
do 15 times 2 plus 1 you get 31 15 times
two
one is equal to 31 and so for 31 x 2
plus 1 is equal to 63 right so in
general you're taking they're saying
each term the each term after the first
determined by multiplying the precinct
term by m and then adding p so we're
multiplying by 2 and then adding 1 and
they want to know what M is so we're
multiplying by 2 so the choice is B B
next problem number three and I'll
switch colors for this one number three
go into a boulder yellow ok Stefan two
tables is their t-shirts so there's
color call our runner they have red
white and blue and then undersized they
have small/medium whoops medium large
and extra-large the table above shows
different colors and sizes of t-shirts
that are available at independence high
school how many different combinations
of color and size are possible well for
each color there are four sizes right so
you just multiply the number of colors
times the number of sizes right there's
four Reds for whites for blues so it's 3
times 4 3 times 4 is equal to 12 choice
B once again that was kind of a just a
very straightforward problem no no real
trick there problem number 4 we're just
we're just going through these problems
for which of the following functions is
and they write let me clear this because
this might take some space ok so they
say for which of this functions is the
following true f of negative 3 is
greater than
f of 3 and hear their choices so choice
a f of X is equal to 4x squared well in
this situation we could just look at
this F of negative 3 and F of 3 is going
to be the same thing because when you
square the X term write F of negative 3
is going to be 4 times 9 which is the
same thing as f of 3 right so that's not
going to help us I got the nine because
I squared the negative 3 square root of
3 so this isn't the right choice f of 3
is equal to F of negative 3 choice a
choice be f of X is going to be equal to
4 well once again this isn't going to be
our choice because f of X is the same
number no matter what right it's four so
there's no way that F of negative 3 is
going to be greater than f of 3 sobeys
not our answer choice e says f of X is
equal to 4 over X this has possibility
so f of negative 3 is what minus four
thirds and F of 3 well no this is going
to work it's going to be positive four
thirds so actually f of 3 is larger than
F of minus three all right so that
doesn't work choice e f of X is equal to
four minus X third this has potential
because F of negative 3 is what it's for
minus minus 27 which equals 31 while F
of 3 is 4 minus 27 which equals minus 24
so f of negative 3 is larger than F of 3
so our answer is e next problem we don't
have to do the last one because we
already found one fits our answer
it solves our problem colors okay i will
switch to this car okay five the force
required to stretch a spring beyond its
natural length is proportional to how
far the spring is being stretched so
this is this is taken physics you'd
probably see this you know the force
necessary is equal to some k right which
is some proportionality constant times
how far you're stretching that's all
they're saying right the force required
to stretch a spring beyond its natural
strength its proportional so that's the
caving is proportional to how far the
spring is being stretched X is how far
it's being stretched if a force of 15
pounds so when f4 is 215 pounds
stretches of spring 8 centimeters so 15
pounds stretches 8 centimeters we've got
to stop select what force in pounds is
needed to spread stretch the spring 20
centimeters be honest natural length so
we can just kind of solve for K in this
equation and then apply it here all
right this is X so 15 is equal to K
times 8 or we could say k is equal to 15
over eight right so we don't k is equal
to 15 / 8 and then here we have well
what happens when X is 20 what is f well
then f is equal to K 15 over 8 times how
far this thing needs to be stretched
beyond its natural whatever the edits
its natural length so 15 over 8 times 2
20 what is this so we can divide the top
and the bottom by 4 so this goes 5 and 2
and what's 5 this is what's five times
15 5 times 15 is 15 75 75 / 2
that's a strange number but it looks
like we do have choices and match that
and that's 37.5 which is choice e next
problem actually I've probably run out
of time so i will do the next problem in
the next video see you soon